hey guys Ryan right here so I wanted to
talk about something I actually spoke
with Tyrone Magnus a few days ago he
called me up he had a couple of
questions uh he wanted to know how to
enlarge your penis size because he is
actually really small it's surprising he
works out a lot to compensate for his
tiny dick no he's [ __ ] he sent me a
photo he's [ __ ] huge but I wanted to
talk about our conversation it supposed
to be like a quick chat but we ended up
talking for an hour and 12 minutes one
of the best moments of my life like we
got along really well he's a really cool
dude [ __ ] lot were very different a
lot of ways but I kind of wanted to talk
about how we're similar and what we
share that is actually true because you
know like he does a lot of reactions I
do a lot of reactions but if you guys
see us where we are pretty different but
there are some things I thought would be
really cool to actually talk about a
little bit we do have very similar
stories I would tell his story but his
story is better cold from his
perspective so if you guys are no story
ask him to do a video on it again
because it is really worth hearing and
it's inspiring to see where he's at now
for my personal story i'll make it
really short i won't go into details I
basically have been pursuing the movie
business since I was a kid when I was a
teenager I tried everything as going
into acting and then I even tried
everything was writing I actually
stopped doing anything movie-related for
like three years I started learning a
lot about business I eventually went
back into writing and doing movie
related stuff because that's my passion
being a movie buff is like the one thing
I know I'm good at so when I saw youtube
I thought it would be great because I
thought like hey you know what I could
put I could do exactly what I want to do
on YouTube and I get access to people
right away like YouTube's worldwide like
for anyone who's considering doing a
YouTube channel here's why I did it
YouTube is worldwide you get access to
like millions of a millions of people
across the globe and you don't have to
go through any [ __ ] you know like in
the typical business way of the movie
industry entertainment industry guy
climbed this little Hatter that everyone
talks about you got to like impress so
many [ __ ] people who you don't care
to impress these people have like
authority over you when they really need
you actually and I thought like [ __ ]
that with YouTube I can just put my [ __ ]
up on this huge website and I could get
access to us
fans and subscribers right away let that
do the talking for me like I don't want
to get someone else's approval of me in
order to see if people will like me I
thought it would be so cool to do this
and sure enough it's panning out exactly
the way I wanted to and it's totally
great it allows me to do what I want to
do and not have to worry about someone
else's validation of me and I know
Tyrone has a very similar philosophy of
that like Tyrone and I really believe in
the power of positivity the power of
setting goals the power of work ethic
especially you know like if you see
Tyrone he used to do a lot of work out
videos and to be that committed to
working I mean everyone knows he's like
super [ __ ] buff he's got those
testicles man [ __ ] and that huge ass
dick that weighs more than any of his
muscles to be that committed to working
out I feel like that level of commitment
is what he's taking into his level of
YouTube success right now like he
acknowledged like I tell him like do you
have like thirty five thousand more subs
than me but we do get similar amount of
views so I think that's cool that he
acknowledged that you know like to know
that hey we still are cat and mouse a
little bit even though he has more subs
the views well that's where the money is
ahead people another thing too that we
thought would be neat is that if we
built up ourselves on YouTube we
wouldn't have to try to get our foot in
the door that people will start coming
to us and I want to talk a lot about
every opportunity come my way but if it
wasn't for you guys I wouldn't have
these opportunities that I've been given
to me lately last year alone I got a
connection i'm legendary you gotta do a
gig for them got a connection and warner
brothers gotta do a gig for them now i
just met up with some people from xbox
latino review my favorite movie site i
have like 30 favorite movie sites and
they're one of them they hit me up to
like I'm just meeting with a lot of
people I might be stewing something with
schmoes know actually yeah like I have
all these opportunities not gonna
divulge Tyrone's but it was part of that
belief of why we did youtube was because
we could have gone the traditional route
of what we wanted to do we have other
things in mind we don't want to just do
reaction videos for the rest of our life
we want to do other things as well
Tyrone has a lot of things in the
pipeline that he wants to do some other
dreams and ambitions and I know he's
going to get at because everything comes
down to the same three basic principle
and him and I really believe it comes
out to your philosophy you know what you
know what you think about your attitude
how you feel about what you know how you
feel towards others that you feel about
yourself taking action taking your
philosophy and attitude and putting it
into action a lot of people like watch
something like the secret and go maybe I
can just think about it long enough but
no you got to take it all and put it
into action and that's what we both been
doing you know there's a phrase that I
heard a long time ago that says work
full-time on your job and part time on
your fortune and I saw YouTube as that
way to sort of start accumulating that
fortune and I used to have a full-time
job like I had a full-time job that I
[ __ ] hated I loved it so much every
day was anxiety depression anger I just
loved it so I would do that 40 hours a
week then I would go home and do YouTube
for about 20 to 30 hours a week did not
work out at all so I gained a lot of
weight if you go back to the first
episode of the movie review when we
started this channel I was super skinny
and then throughout the year and a half
I like gained a lot of weight now I'm
like working out again I want to get
like a Tyrone body I was able to replace
my job because of you guys you guys
allow me to replace my job I am able to
do this now part-time but I'm making
more money than when I did a full time
job that's awesome and it's really
really a big thank you to you guys like
I mean that from the bottom of my heart
like I know I talk about a lot of things
that a lot of people don't like to talk
about like you know I just revealed some
opportunities that I got I reveal that
yeah I do make money on YouTube it
really goes back to you dudes and that's
something Tyrone and I really believe in
too is that yes he does make money
everyone knows that he also has a job
one thing we really believe is really
strongly tending to our subscribers
tending to the fans because it's you
guys who really make the channel it's
you guys who really matter I remember
realizing that when we were at like 10
subscribers I've been grateful forever
to this day like we jump up anywhere
from like six to eight hundred followers
on average a day now I love every single
one of you guys I'm not just saying that
because i remember when i had 10
followers i remember thinking if I know
how to just 10
to each individual person that I have at
this ten and to tend to those who
subscribe you know some people focus on
I want to get more views I want to get
more subscribers I've always felt that I
just want to focus on those people who
are already subscribed and then
everything else will kind of take care
of itself and so Tyrone and I really
believe on that really tending to our
subs and I think that's why people like
us is because they know we're very
genuine about it yeah you know we both
get haters like I think I get way more
heat that's as I say some things that
are just a little bit too offensive
every now and again but Tyrone is
someone who does get haters he said
people call him the n-word often in case
you guys know what that word is it's n I
gger say it out loud if you don't know
what that word means say to your parents
they'll tell you what it means but we do
get haters that and one thing that we
get haters on to is like who watches
someone do a reaction you know I think
Tyrone and I give opinions on the videos
we like to give our insights and another
thing too is like I got asked Tyrone
this when he did that Star Wars reaction
I asked him like do you think that if
you were in the theaters you would have
done that wiki noise and he said
probably not he wasn't faking it for the
camera and I don't fake my stuff either
the thing is though is when you're
filming a video and you're aware that
there's a lot of people watching you it
brings out a certain energy level in you
like I'll watch trailers alone sometimes
and you know like I'll get excited but
when I'm with a buddy like my energy
comes out in even more that is authentic
what we're doing it actually does take a
certain level of work to actually do
that it's not about putting all this
energy and it's not about faking or
forcing a reaction but it's about
allowing yourself to be you while I
cameras pointed at you for example every
time someone comes on this channel I
always tell them the one thing I tell
them is something Tyrone and I really
believe in which is the power of
believing in yourself and being yourself
I have a cheesy ass quote but I really
live by it I tell people the word unique
starts with the letter U for a reason so
to be unique just got be yourself and I
think about how people come on this
channel and they're always so concerned
about are people gonna like me what if I
don't have a reaction and I'm always
like don't give a [ __ ] about any of that
whatever you're feeling
just let it out and let people see it
and just be yourself and it actually
takes work to be yourself it takes work
to just allow people to see who you are
to see what your feeling on the inside
its progress its process if you could do
that it's I could see why people might
be drawn to it cuz I'll admit up until
we were out like sixty thousand
subscribers I always had a question of
why do people like watching reaction
videos but then it started to dawn on me
that's like oh it's because you know
like I get why there are some reactors
who go places and some who don't it's
because like people like Tyrone and I
like to be ourselves and really show
that energy like we're aware that
thousands of people are going to be
watching our videos so it brings out a
level of energy in us and it's because
we know you guys are watching so we'd
like to tend to that and really show you
guys how we're feeling so yeah we deal
with haters he deals with trolls better
than I do I know I haven't talked word
for word about everything Tyrone and I
talked about because like for most of it
like a lot of it i'm not going to reveal
because it's very personal this is all
thoughts and attitudes that were
conjuring up after my conversation with
him and it makes sense how we are sort
of at similar levels because we have
similar point of views on things you
know when we certainly have our
differences and the reason why we have a
difference is is because i work on
embracing myself he works on him bracing
himself and through that we got two
different individuals and i really hope
to work with this guy one day like i
really want to work with tyrone the main
reason i'm doing this video hopefully
you stay till the end for this part I
want Tyrone Magnus to quit his job here
you guys who really follow Tyrone you'll
know he has a job that's outside of
YouTube I really think he should quit he
didn't tell me the income he exactly
makes off youtube I'm hearing it and I'm
like dude you can totally quit your job
you could do more videos he can produce
better quality videos like I'm a fan of
Tyrone Magnus and I was telling I'm like
dude I know you got more subs than me if
we get similar amount of views and you
have more substi- will be fine I really
wanted to quit his job because I think
you'd be so inspiring I didn't really
talk a lot about like how much I hated
my job when I was doing this channel I
didn't really talk about when I was able
to quit my job now I mention it but I
think it would be so inspiring for so
many people to see some
one like Tyrone who was building this
channel then he was able to go out there
and replace his full-time job because he
was able to just tend to his subscribers
like that would be so inspiring Tyrone
you want to get to 1 million subs faster
quit your [ __ ] job if you get a job
going to male stripping let's face it
you got a big [ __ ] your [ __ ] buff
your black [ __ ] beautiful to look at
it so quit your goddamn job another
thing too is I want him and Gator Martin
and Cooley to come out to california in
the summer I thought of a three-part
short film series that we could do where
it's about the reactors coming together
like we would actually be scripted and I
thought I'd be cool if like one video
was on my channel and other on Tyrone's
and other on Gators that would be so
[ __ ] cool to do that so if you guys
can just start telling Tyrone to quit
his job that would be great and if you
can convince Gator and Tyrone to come
out to California so we could put this
short film together that would also be
splendid anyway guys thanks for tuning
in you can subscribe to the real rejects
porfavor and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter Tyrone is
always like 1 million subscribers I just
want product placement if I can just get
25 thousand followers on Instagram and
post a picture and get paid thousands of
dollars for it that'd be nice I mean
that's why [ __ ] you guys and then
gonna benefit you and it will benefit me